i want to congratulate you you got
nominated your nominee for two emmys
this year three oh so three ten years
i saw three on my sheet and i i took one
off oh just because i felt some i'm like
no no that's too much i'm going to take
you down a notch no no it says here too
but that's great three emmys yeah emmy's
four
nailed two for nailed it one is
outstanding host one is for the actual
show um and then the other one's for my
special outstanding writing that's
fantastic yeah i'm really excited about
that one because i like i mean i'm
excited about the nailed it one two but
like the stand up one and i put like my
whole heart and soul into it and i
toured with it for a long time and then
i just spent so much time and then the
look of it it all came together the
opening yeah i just it's my it's my
masterpiece how long how long uh a set
is it on the special is it like an hour
it's an hour that's fantastic
good for you yeah
i'm curious so do you have plans for the
emmys like what are you going to do how
are you going to approach this well i'm
going to go yeah
some people don't some people don't i'm
going good and i'm going to wear a
fabulous dress and i'm going to look so
[ __ ] good i'm going we'll lose to
rupaul
uh twice
and then you have this all
right then on the way home i'll get a
flat
and then i'll cry a little bit goes in
the tire or losing to rupaul again um
and i'll be like yesterday because you
know you're going to lose to rupaul and
then i get home and then i'll get ready
i'll go to the other emmys because i
have to go to two to go to the creative
arts and then the emmy emmys right um i
don't really have a plan i'm rooting for
you i want you to win this yeah me too
but you know what it doesn't really
matter if you win or not you get to go
and you have this amazing dress you're
going to have a great time yeah i had
fun losing last year
but i will say there wasn't enough food
they put just bottles and bottles of
wine on the table and no food well the
situation i think last year was because
of kovitz oh yeah they were trying to
thread this weird needle so they said
we'll have people in a room but it'll be
a strange room
strange like half outside half not
outside yeah and there'll be a mister
that's suiting disinfected over everyone
like it's a salad bar all the time
and uh and we're going to reference
kovit a lot which will be kind of a
downer
and we don't want to show i don't know
why they didn't want people to have food
but they didn't but they put some wine
there because i think they wanted to
grab some of that uh that golden globe
vibe
of people getting a little you know
trashed and crazy yeah so um so i don't
know i this year is going to be very
different i think because we all know
it's completely
done we're having a great time